y
hola muy bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de la entrevista de france 24 en esta
oportunidad vamos a reflexionar sobre el
lenguaje inclusivo incorporado y
adoptado por muchísimas personas aunque
también resistido por muchas otras un
tema que ha abierto un debate que va
mucho más allá del lenguaje y de la
gramática nos acompaña a carolina tos y
ella es doctora en lingüística magister
en análisis del discurso y licenciada y
también profesora en letras por la
universidad de buenos aires de argentina
carolina a todos y muchísimas gracias
por su presencia en la entrevista de
france 24
bueno carolinas vayamos al origen no
para comenzar el lenguaje como se sabe
no es estático suele acompañar procesos
y también transformaciones sociales
culturales en este sentido de que nos
habla el nacimiento del lenguaje
inclusivo
mira de santiago primero habría que
hacer una distinción entre lo que es
lenguaje no sexista del lenguaje
inclusivo de género
el lenguaje no sexista se forjó con los
movimientos feministas y luego más que
nada a fines de los ochentas jordan de
la década del 90 se inventó en las
publicaciones diversas guías de lenguaje
no sexista que justamente la pretensión
más central tiene que ver con la
visibilización del género femenino en
los discursos y entonces una de las
características fundamentales era evitar
el masculino genérico no en el español
es decir por ejemplo en vez de decir
todos no hacen un desdoblamiento y decir
todos y todas y así hay muchos otros
recursos tenemos por ejemplo el uso de
las barras el uso de la equis
en astérix porque esos dos este signos
gráficos la verdad que ya no se gustan
tanto y después si hay otros usos que
tienen que ver con las perífrasis con
éste nominalización es con este algunos
buenos sustantivos sin marcas de género
que bueno justamente se usan para
realizar ese efecto de sentido
ahora bien el lenguaje inclusivo que más
o menos comienza a formarse ya en este
nuevo siglo y la verdad que en argentina
fue un boom a partir del 2018 con las
diferentes manifestaciones no por
cuestiones de género que wok está en el
país él morfema no que justamente
emergió es live y ya estos movimientos
lo que busca es romper el binarismo sí
buenos sistemas en español es decir ska
para el femenino masculino y justamente
una de las estrategias es el uso de nada
pero sumado a alumnos de los recursos
que son menciones que justamente lo que
hacen es no visibilizar el género no
como por ejemplo la equis que se utiliza
mucho en la escritura lo que sucede es
que claro el problema era la
organización que si es algo que se puede
dar a partir del máxima precisamente a
lo que hacías referencia no este
lenguaje no sexista y como vos decías
hace estallar al masculino genérico no
la lengua no identificaba a muchísimas
personas e inclusivo lo que interesa es
interpelar a identidades que están
alejadas no de los binarismo da lugar al
respeto a la forma en que cada uno desea
ser nombrado verdad allí es donde radica
muchísima de su fuerza y de su necesidad
verdad carolina
exacto en realidad y muchas veces lo que
notamos en el libro lo que escribimos
con valeria sardi en las entrevistas y
los análisis que estuvimos haciendo de
diferentes textos es que más que no sea
más que la molestia por esta cuestión de
alterar no esté el lenguaje el discurso
tiene que ver con esta molestia por
mostrar las disidencias sexo genéricas
es decir estas entidades estas
identidades los que estuvieron son
lanzadas tradicionalmente todavía este
ejercen resistencia y se ve claramente
por ejemplo en las redes sociales en los
medios masivos las posturas es como que
son muy polarizadas no están en contra
oa favor y los que están en contra la
verdad que lo que hemos este visto
también a partir del libro es mucha
violencia mucha agresión verbal no está
la cuestión de directamente desestimar
el uso del lenguaje inclusivo por lo que
digamos por un argumento lingüístico
obviamente es aceptado y es más en el
libro damos cuenta de las cuestiones
positivas y negativas del lenguaje
inclusivo de los argumentos a favor y
los argumentos en contra sino que se ve
directamente como te decía hace un
ratito esta agresión y este rechazo no
las personas que no coinciden con el
binarismo tradicional de lo normativo en
unos momentos te voy a preguntar
específicamente sobre el libro que
escribieron junto a valeria sardi
lenguaje inclusivo y es si en las aulas
antes quisiera plantear el tema del
lenguaje como poder no el lenguaje es
poder es un espacio de creación absoluta
de sentido no y poner el foco así de
cierta manera es como iluminar formas de
expresión que históricamente han
generado por lo menos sentidos que
pueden ser considerados de manera
polémica por los llamarlos de alguna
manera no un ejemplo clásico es que
hombres sea sinónimo de ser humano
verdad
es que en realidad y bueno ese es un
ejemplo que es
es casi perfecto digamos para dar cuenta
de este fenómeno porque hasta hace poco
en los libros no se ve el 70 del 80 la
anatomía humana y el cuerpo del hombre y
el hombre siempre como referencia no y
este las mujeres generalmente son las
hadas o subordinadas a ese poder y eso
también se ve bueno en los usos este
sexistas en también este
pensemos todo lo que tiene que ver con
las expresiones discriminatorias no
sobre la mujer
también tiene que ver con las
profesiones no recién hasta hace unos
años no cada vez están circulando más
las profesiones en femenino pero hasta
hace muy poco no por ejemplo hace poco
fue jurada de una tesis y éramos tres
juradas y el día
plantilla de ese dictamen estaba
masculino y dijimos no tenemos que poner
una de las partes somos las tres las
pulgadas entonces ahí vemos como en
estas cuestiones cotidianas estas estas
problemáticas y estas controversias
panea mereciendo pero el lenguaje
inclusivo definitivamente ya ingresó a
las aulas verdad como decíamos
previamente junto a valeria sardi son
ambas autoras del libro de lenguaje
inclusivo y es si en las escuelas
aclaramos a la audiencia que es y hace
referencia a la educación sexual
integral contanos carolina que está
sucediendo en las escuelas entre
docentes estudiantes también con equipos
directivos y las familias
bueno es un tema muy polémico y
controvertido porque bueno hay este
muchas posturas y acá se juegan
diferentes imaginarios de la lengua la
lengua como tesoro es decir como esa
lengua que hay que descender que hay que
mantener importa y sabemos bien que la
lengua como bien dijiste es cambios no
nosotros hablamos en variedades
discursivas o sea lo único que no que no
hay la lengua inquietud a vivir a este
movimiento todo el tiempo bueno eso
digamos este por un lado pues también
están los imaginarios de la lengua como
un reflejo entonces supuestamente es el
campo cambios en la sociedad la lengua
lo tendría que este digamos de alguna
manera reflejada pero acá sabemos que
esto pasa la lengua no es mágica sino
que éste
los discursos lo que hacen justamente es
visualizar ciertas problemáticas pero si
no hay cambios sociales políticos que
acompañen esas luchas bueno todo a ver
transformaciones y también esta
representación de la lengua como lucha
que hemos mencionaba al principio como
los discursos ponen en escena todos
estas estas problemáticas y estos
discursos silenciados estas identidades
que han sido este rechazadas pueden
emerger pueden visualizarse y lo que
sucede en la escuela es que claro
justamente están estas representaciones
y también la escuela siempre ha tenido
una tradición normativa entonces bueno
qué pasa cuando se introducen algunos
usos que de alguna manera entran en
tensión con este la normativa de la
lengua española
qué bueno justamente la rae
española está en desacuerdo de esos usos
pero los mismos estudiantes lo utilizan
también los docentes hasta los estudios
en argentina es que tanto las algunas
instituciones terciarias y muchas
universidades
dominando resoluciones la posibilidad de
usar lenguaje inclusivo por ejemplo para
exámenes para tesis es decir no es una
obligación no es una bajada de cruzarlo
pero aquel que quiere utilizarlo lo
puede hacer pensemos por ejemplo que es
decir que están relacionadas con estos
temas por ejemplo con la comunidad trans
y es necesario que aparezcan estos usos
y bueno lo que se da en las aulas
obviamente va a depender de canadá de
todas las instituciones en particular
pero hay conflictos hay tensiones y yo
creo que eso es lo rico del lenguaje
inclusivo que puede producir debates
puede producir la reflexión en whisky
acá creo que es un momento especial muy
nutritivo para poder a partir de este
hecho que podemos estar o no de acuerdo
pero poder generar esa reflexión
lingüística y especialmente en los
jóvenes no yo creo que eso es
absolutamente relevante totalmente para
ir finalizando carolina el lenguaje
inclusivo lenguaje no sexista también se
ubica de alguna manera por fuera
lo puramente lingüístico o gramatical
hay en su uso una manera de pronunciarse
políticamente un modo de plantarse ante
el mundo
hay muchos lingüistas por ejemplo cariño
y venías a leer y varios seguramente ya
vidente de algunos que justamente lo que
ellos postulan yo también estoy de
acuerdo con esta visión es que el
lenguaje inclusivo es una intervención
cursiva con una gran impronta política
es justamente quiere éste producir
determinados efectos de sentido a mí me
interesa o bueno me gusta más que nada
definirlo como ese lenguaje inclusivo
comunista redención discursiva ya cada
vez que vemos una equis o una es una
marca disruptiva no quedes acomoda el
interlocutor al lector y de alguna
manera nos hace
es decir un que se está x que se está de
bueno hay algo que de alguna manera
quiere salir quiere emerger y me parece
que esa es la fuerza más inclusiva
absolutamente carolina a todos y
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
la entrevista de france 24 ha sido un
placer dialogar con usted un placer para
mí muchísimas gracias por la invitación
no por favor nuevamente gracias a usted
ya nuestra audiencia como siempre le
invitamos a continuar informándose en el
resto de nuestra profesión y también en
transmitir otro puntocom
[Música]